[Music]  that blended family how did you make  that work you know for us is all about  the kids  JLo certainly fits right in with irods  girls check out Lopez getting them and  her daughter Emmy glam last night for a  dance recital to her music  we just had an awesome awesome time  watching three little girls  maybe that's the new way of families I  came from a broken home and I think it's  super important for your parents to  stick together and seeing the kids how  happy they get they were all together  mr. priceless today the dad was hard at  work shooting shark tank the guest  panelist is back as the show celebrates  its 10th season but our he JLo just too  busy for marriage everybody now talks  about when is she going to get a ring  things at our own pace what do you think  of that she's the queen we are in a  great place in our lives  we're raising our children for them and  that's what we strive to do every day